[MUSIC]
If an applicant does get an interview,
how would you recommend they prepare for
that interview?
>> Well, first of all, if an applicant
gets an interview, congratulations.
[LAUGH]
>> That's a really good sign [INAUDIBLE]
[CROSSTALK]
>> Yeah,
we usually interview about two
candidates for every spot that we have.
So number one,
the word prepare is a really good one.
If you've made it this far,
and worked this hard,
treat this as an important
part of the process.
Unlike some other schools,
we use our alumni for interviewers, and
they are all around the globe.
We try to match you with people from
your country, maybe perhaps an industry
that you're in if possible, currently in,
so they really understand you.
And it's in two parts.
The first half an hour
is primarily evaluative.
And then the last 15
minutes it's a chance for
you to meet someone from the community.
So come prepared with
the mindset to do both.
And the first part we're going to be
it's a behavioral based interview, so
the stories that we were talking about
before, come ready to tell them.
We're going to, want to know
about what you're most proud of.
What was the context?
What was the challenge?
What did you do?
How did you do it?
And then what was the impact?
So expect some probing
around those stories.
And then on the second part, it's fun.
Our community's so tight.
[LAUGH]
>> I enjoyed my interview a lot, actually.
>> Actually?
>> I had a great time.
>> Yeah.
And did you enjoy the interviewer?
>> I did, it's pretty expert, actually.
It's really good at really drawing
stories out of me rather kind of in like
intense questions.
And by the end of it, I felt that there
was somebody that I'd really got to know.
And somebody who was part of a community
I was excited to be a part of.
So the interview was actually really great
for me and getting excited for school.
>> And that's a wonderful way
to help with the second tip.
That last part of the interview,
it's a gift.
It's a chance to develop a relationship.
Come prepared with some questions that you
want to know about Stanford, obviously,
but see it as just one entry step to
being part of a bigger community.